gençler Merhaba hepiniz hoş geldiniz map
taramasına devam ediyoruz konumuz
canlıların karakteristik özellikleri
başka bir ifadeyle ortak özellikleri
yine hocalarımızla bir araya geldik
neler söyleyebiliriz ne ekleyebiliriz
öğrencilerimize nasıl yol gösterebiliriz
bu tarz soruların cevabını küçük küçük
karaladı ve düzenli not haline getirdik
Şimdi onları size aktaracağım Öyleyse ne
diyoruz Hadi gelin birlikte öğrenelim
canlıların ortak özellikleri bir başka
ifadeyle karakteristik özellikleri
Aslında çok fazla başlık var Her bir alt
başlığı detaylandı konuya girerken Milli
Eğitim bize demiş ki Çevrenizde
canlıları birbirinden ayıran özellikler
neler olabilir söyleyiniz aslında bir
sonraki konu olan sınıflandırmada çok
daha güzel çok daha detaylı bilgilere
ulaşacaksınız Ama şu anda sadece genel
kültür tadında Bu soruya cevap vermeniz
isteniyor başka bir şey istenmiyor
ikinci soruda ise canlılarda gözlenen
bazı özellikler cansızlarda da
gözlenebilir mi denmiş biz buna şöyle
yaklaştık Hani canlıda da cansız da da
kütle hacim enerji tarzında kavramlar
olacak işte Uzayda yer kaplayacak belli
bir ağırlığa sahip olacak ekstradan ya
da işte bir enerji barındıracak ya da
enerji açığa çıkaracak şeklinde aslında
hani genel bir ifade kullanılabilir görs
verilmiş bu görselde 4 tane canlıdan
bahsedilmiş işte bakteri çiçeklerden bir
tane örnek verilmiş mantar işte bir tane
de hayvan örneği verilmiş fakat sorunun
köküne baktığımız zaman bu canlılarda
ortak olarak gözlenen özellikleri
arkadaşlarınızla tartışınız dendiğinde
Biz burada gözlenen kasıt acaba bilinen
özellik mi Yani aslında şunu söylemeye
çalışıyorum ben sizin sınıfınızda
öğretmen olsaydım şunu yapardım ne nir
hocam O işte gidin bir grup bakteriyi
araştırsın bir grup bitkileri araştırsın
bir grup mantarları araştırsın bir grup
da hayvanları araştırsın ve sonra gelsin
ne araştırdı Ne öğrendiyse bana anlatsın
Mesela şimdi şu anda bakteriye bakarak
bir şey söyleyemem çünkü bu mantıktan
yola çıktığımda bakteriyi zaten hani
mikroskopta bile zorla görebiliyorsun
zorla gördüğün bakteri ile ilgili ne
bilebilirsin ama gidip de bir akademik
kaynak açtığın zaman işte bakterilerin
bir kısmı Oksijenli solunum yapar bir
kısmı oksijensiz solunum yapar bir kısmı
fermentasyon yapar işte bazıları
fotosentetik bazıları kemosentetik
bunlar prokaryottur bunlar tek
hücrelidir işte bazıları Kamçı ile aktif
bir şekilde yer değiştirme hareketi
yapar şeklinde aslında bana Araştırma
sonuçlarını söyleyecek ya da bitkiler
hocam damarsız tohumsuz damarlı tohumsuz
damarlı tohumlu olarak ayrılabilir
tohumlular açık kapalı kapalılar tek
çenekli çift çenekli olarak ayrılabilir
meyve vermek bütün bitkilerin ortak
özelliği değildir çiçek açmak bütün
bitkilerin ortak özelliği değildir
tohumla üremek bütün bitkilerin ortak
özelliği değildir bitkilerde kök sistemi
farklılık gösterebilir bazıları kazık
kök bazıları saçak köke sahiptir gibi
Aslında bilgiyi bana getirecektin
mantarlarla ilgili Konuşacağın zaman
işte içerisinde saprotrof yani çürükçül
canlılar parazitler var ya da mutualist
var gibi cümleler kurup işte dünyada
madde döngüsü ile ilgili tepkimelerde en
çok rol alan canlardır işte bazıları tek
hücrelidir bazıları çok hücrelidir
mesela Maya mantarı vardır Maya mantarı
bölünerek ya da tomurcuklanarak
çoğalırken diğerleri hif ve misal
oluşturur gibi hocam Ne diyorsun İşte
bunların hepsini öğreneceksin Yani ben
bu canlıya baktığım zaman Hocam ben bir
mantar görüyorum ama bu mantarla ilgili
sana bir şey söyleyemem sadece görüyorum
dediğinde işte ben de diyeceğim ki Hadi
git bir akademik kaynak bul hadi git
birazcık İnternette araştırma yap yaz
bakalım Mantarlar alemi dendiğinde ne
çıkıyor karş mesela hayvanlarla ilgili
Konuşacak olan grubu ele alalım işte
kordalılar var kordas zlar var sırtta
sinir şeridi olan karında sinir şeridi
olanlar var Balıklar amfibiler
sürüngenler Kuşlar memeliler şeklinde
kordalılar ayırıyorlar Diğer taraftan
sünger sölenter solucan yumuşakça eklem
bacaklı Deresi dikenli diye başka bir
grup var şeklinde aslında hani biraz
daha konunun içerisine girmenizi
isterdim Eğer bu şekilde ders işliyor
olsaydık ama bunların hepsi öğrenilecek
Merak etmeyin arkadaşlar burada
ekstradan sizi böyle Zorlayacak bir şey
yok şimdi canlıların ortak özelliklerine
baktığımızda Bir de alt paragrafta da
karakteristik özellikler şeklinde ifade
kullandığı için aslında karakteristik
özellikler ortak özellikler biraz daha
böyle açılması gerekiyor fakat Her zaman
söylediğim bir şeyi size Şimdiden
söyleyeyim biyolojide bütün hepsi
hiçbiri tarzında bir ifade bilimsel
değildir Dolayısıyla biz bu kelimeyle
cümleye başlamak istemiyoruz ve
sevmiyoruz Şimdi burada bütün canlılarda
diye bir ifade kullanmayacağım O yüzden
baştan anlaşalım
canlılarda ortak olan ya da olmasını
beklediğim özellikler şeklinde mesela
Hücresel yapı Evet canlılarda Hücresel
yapı var hücre zarı sitoplazma gibi
yapılar var metabolik faaliyetler
hücrenin içerisinde gerçekleşir her
hücre Bir önceki hücrenin bölünmesiyle
meydana gelir bu nedir hocam hücre
teorisidir Tamam hücre konusunda Bunu
zaten detaylandı cağız organizasyon Bu
kitabın son konusu Aslında organizasyon
büyük akademik kaynaklarda üçe ayrılır
hücre düzeyinde organizma düzeyinde ve
ekosistem düzeyinde şeklinde okul
kitabımız hücre düzeyinde ve organizma
düzeyinde olan başlığı almış 3üncü
başlığı ayırmayı sadece popülasyon
komünite ve ekosistem kavramlarını
kullanmış bunu da zaten zamanı
geldiğinde söyleyeceğim beslenme
canlılar ototrof olabilir heterotrof
olabilir her iki özelliği de içeriyor
olabilir detaylandı burada çok önemli
bir madde var genç meslektaşlarımız
danan da diğer öğretmenlerim adına
ricada bulunmak istiyorum Enerji Üretim
ve tüketim ifadesi yerine Enerji
dönüşümü ifadesini kullanmak her zaman
daha sağlıklıdır bir kere enerji Yoktan
var edilemez var olan enerji yok
edilemez Bu bir İkincisi burada bir
ifade var Enerji üretimini Her canlı
yapar diyor ama biz biliyoruz ki
klamidyalar klamidyanın bazı türlerinde
enerji üret Bunlar enerji paraziti var
olan bir bilgi var o bilgiyi kullanmamız
lazım ve bu bilgi böyle çok uç noktadan
alınmış bir bilgi değil İçinizde ileride
Hekim olacak olan doktor olmak isteyen
arkadaşlarımız var biliyorum onlar kadın
doğum stajına geldiği zaman 4 sınıfta
dönem 4te mesela Kadın hastalıklarında
enfeksiyon hastalıklarında klamidya
denilen bir canlı öğrenecekler ve bunun
enerji paraziti olduğunu öğrenecekler
sonra diyecekler ki hani bütün canlılar
enerji üretiyordu işte böyle bir şey yok
bu canlı enerji paraziti ama Enerji
dönüşümü yapabilir yani başka birinden
aldığı bir materyali kendi ihtiyaçlarına
uygun bir şekilde kullanabilir O yüzden
enerji üretim tüketimi demek yerine
canlılar Enerji dönüşümü yaparlar demek
çok daha bilimsel çok daha mantıklı
metabolizma tüm yapım yıkım boşaltım ise
metabolik faaliyetler sırasında oluşan
artık maddelerin uzaklaştırılmasıdır
hücreden ya da vücuttan büyüme gelişmeye
dikkat edeceğiz İkisi aynı şey değil
detaylandı hocam üreme Her canlı üremek
zorunda değil Hatta sınıflandırmada
şöyle bir bilgi öğreneceksiniz farklı
türlerin çiftleşmesiyle oluşan
yavrularda üreme kabiliyeti olmayabilir
uyarılara tepki etkiye tepki veririz
bunu gözle de görebilirsiniz moleküler
düzeyde de olabilir yani hocam moleküler
düzeyden kastın ne mesela içeride bir
sistemde değişiklik olduğu zaman sizin
vücudunuzda buna bir tepki oluşur çok
basitleştir Alim susama hissi mesela
değil mi Bir susama hissi var ne
yaparsın susadım dersin gidersin
kalkarsın su içersin şimdi bu hissiyat
nasıl oluştu işte hipotalamusta ozmotik
reseptörler var Onlar kanın yoğunluğunu
su miktarını tuz miktarını ölçebiliyor
Vesaire Vesaire Vesaire sonra sana bir
sinyal oluşturuyor kalk su iç diyor ve
sen de kalkıp su içiyorsun gibi etkiye
tepki davranışlarımız var sadece yani
işte bana dokundu Ben de ona tepki
verdim tarzında düşünmeyin moleküler
seviyeyi de düşünün burada son olarak
homeostazi kelimesi var homeostazi İç
denge demek kararlı ortam demek ya da
bir ortamı kararlı tutmaya çalışmak
demek Buna da kabaca örnek ver hemen
Hocam mesela Vücut sıcaklığını 36,5 s
dce civarındadır 39 olması 35 olması
tehlikedir değil mi küçük dar aralıkta
bazı değerlerin tutulması durumudur
Aslında homeostazi bu şekilde bilirseniz
En azından çok daha rahat Yorum
yapabilirsiniz ve son olarak iki tane
kavramdan bahsedelim Varyasyon variation
çeşitlilik tür içi çeşitlilik ve
adaptasyon Bunlar da karakteristik özel
özellikler şimdi tek tek bütün
özellikleri vurgulayacak şekilde gidelim
Hücresel yapı Bir canlının canlılık
özelliği gösteren en küçük yapı birimi
hücredir ve dolayısıyla hücre Aslında
metabolik faaliyetlerin gerçekleştiği
yerd hücreler temelde prokaryot ve
ökaryot olmak üzere ikiye ayrılır
prokaryot Pro Öncü demek arkadaşlar
karyo çekirdek demek aslında burada
gerçek bir çekirdek yapısı yok DNA'nın
bulunduğu bir bölge var çekirdeksiz ve
spesifik organel içermeyen canlılar
prokaryot canlılardır nedir hocam mesela
kloroplastlar Yok mitokondrileri yok
işte çekirdekleri Yok sentrozomlar yok
vesaire vesaire Kim bunlar bakteriler ve
arkeler ileride öğreneceğiz detaylı bir
şekilde ökaryot hücrelere baktığınız
zaman çekirdek ve zarlı organel içeren
hücrelerden bahsediyoruz Kim bunlar
protista amip öglena paramesyum gibi
canlıların olduğu Alem ya da bitkiler
alemi ya da Mantarlar alemi ya da
hayvanlar alemi şeklinde ökaryot
hücreler ve ökaryot Alemleri
öğreneceksiniz bakın burada A'da amip
B'de öglena cde paramesyum Bunlar
protista organizasyon Ben eskiden beri
iş bölümü ifadesi kullanıyorum ama iş
bölümü ile alakalı Tabii ki bu kadar
basitleştirmek söyledim organizasyon Bu
kitabın sonunda kendi içerisinde de
ayrılmış ne dedim hücre düzeyinde
organizma düzeyinde ve Aslında ekosistem
sistem düzeyinde şuraya baktığımızda
bileşenlerin bir araya gelmesi
kendisinden daha kompleks bir yapı
oluşturması durumudur Aslında
organizasyon basitten karmaşa gitme
durumudur organizasyon baktığınız zaman
işte atomlar molekülleri meydana
getiriyor moleküller organelleri
organeller de bir araya gelerek işte
hücre zarını hücrenin temel yapılarını
oluşturuyor hücreler dokuları dokular
organları organlar sistemleri
sistemlerde organizmayı meydana
getiriyor Burada dikkat etmeni istediğim
bir şey var Bak bütün canlılar Çok
hücreli olamaz Bütün canlılar dokulaşma
mantığı olmaz bazı canlılar hücrede
durur mesela prokar canlıları düşünelim
bakteriler ve arkeler gibi ya da
protista alemi içerisindeki birçok
canlıyı düşünelim işte amip öglen
Paramesyum gibi canlılar onlar tek
hücrelidir hücre düzeyinde
kalmışlardır şimdi beslenmenin mantığına
bakalım neden beslenir canlılar Aslında
teorik olarak ü tane temel neden vardır
Bunlardan bir tanesi Yapı bileşenleri
oluşturmak ikincisi enerji temin etmek
Biz bir Üçüncüyü de ekledik düzenleyici
molekülleri almak mesela mineral gibi
vitamin gibi insan bunun üçünü de
yapıyor mesela ama bitkiler 2'yi
yapmıyor Çünkü bitki 2'yi Yani neden iki
amaçlı yapmıyor Çünkü bitki enerjisini
ışıktan alıyor gibi Aslında canlı
Alemleri içerisinde beslenmenin mantığı
biraz farklıdır yani canlı hocam ototrof
olabilir heterotrof olabilir hem ototrof
hem heterotrof olabilir ve beslenmenin
temelinde Aslında ihtiyaç duyulan
maddeleri almak vardır ototrof kendi
besini kendi üreten demektir ileride
öğreneceksiniz fotosentez kemosentez
yapan canlılar heterotroflar dışarı
bağımlıdır kendi besinlerini üretemezler
parazitler saprotrof mesela mantarlar
hayvanlar parazit canlılar Bunlar
heterotrof dışa bağımlıdır Yani
beslenmeden dışarıdan yemek yemeden
hayatta kalamazsın gibi burada bir canlı
var ki öglena öglena hem ototrof hem
heterotrof öglena Işık varlığında
fotosentez yapar yoksa besini dışarıdan
alır miksotrof kelimesi kullanılıyor
burada Onu da şuraya yazabiliriz mikso
trof Tamam peki gördüğünüz gibi Aslında
biyolojiye giriş tarzında devam ediyoruz
hala Çünkü bunların her biri sizin 4
yıllık biyoloji eğitiminiz boyunca
aslında başka başka başlıklar olarak
gelecek işte fotosentez kemosentez
metabolik solunum ATP nükleik asitler
hücre konusu sınıflandırma Siz şu anda
sadece biyoloji ile alakalı bir fikir
ediniyorsunuz çok canınız sıkılmasın
Tamam işte her şeyi öğrenmek zorundayım
tek bir derste hepsini bitirmek
zorundayım sor bakalım Biz onu
yapabilmiş miyiz Hayır enerji üretim ve
tüketimi yerine ne demeliydim Enerji
dönüşümü demeliydim canlılar solunum
yapar fermentasyon yapar enerji
üretebilmek adına ya da işte fotosentez
kemo sentez tepkimelerine başvurur o
tepkimelerde de besin üretir buraya
baktığımızda en çok karıştırılan şeyin
şu olduğunu biliyoruz hocam büyük
Molekülün küçük moleküle dönüşmesi
Mesela bir proteinin amino asite
dönüşmesi bir glikojenin glukoza
dönüşmesi Bu bir hidroliz dirir Yani bir
sindirimdir ancak elde ettiğiniz o küçük
molekülü glikozu aminoasiti yağ asidini
gidip de içindeki enerjiyi alacak
şekilde parçalamanın İşte o solunum ya
da fermentasyon
solunum ikiye ayrılır oksijenli
oksijensiz solunum fermentasyon
solunumun dışında bir enerji üretme
yolağı Adır diyelim Şimdilik burada
bırakalım Tamam başka da ötesine
söylemeyelim ama fermentasyon solunum
olmadığını lütfen vurgulayın Kendi
kendinize ve dikkat edin ATP
molekülünden bahsedilir ATP bizim
vücudumuzda yapılıp yıkılan depolanmayan
içerisindeki yüksek enerjili bağın yıkı
masasıyla açığa çıkan enerjiyle
tepkimeler imizi gerçekleştirdiğimiz
bazı tepkimeler imizi
gerçekleştirdiğimiz enerji molekülü müz
metabolizma yapım yıkım tepkimelerinin
tamamına denir Aslında buradaki
kavramlara dikkat edelim anabolizma
yapım özümleme aynı şeydir Yani bir şeyi
sentezlemek yapmak katabolizma ise yıkım
burada baktığınız zaman işte yadımlama
diye bir kelime daha koyabilirler
bakıyorum Hocam küçük moleküller büyük
moleküllere dönüşmüş ve su açığa çıkmış
bu
dehidrasyonda
Dehidrasyon küçük moleküller büyük
moleküllere dönüşürken açığa su çıkması
olayıdır ama buradan şöyle küçük bir not
almanı istiyorum her su açığa çıkan
Reaksiyon Dehidrasyon değildir Tamam
mesela hocam bak su buharı çıktı solunum
yaptım solunum bir yıkım olayıdır ama
Dehidrasyon bir sentez olayıdır nasıl da
çok fazla bilgi var değil mi İşte
hepsini zamanı geldiğinde tek tek
öğreneceksin rahat ol Tam tersini
düşünelim büyük moleküller su ile
parçalanıp küçük moleküle dönüşüyor Buna
da ileride hidroliz diyeceğiz hidr su
Liz parçalamak su ile parçalamak ama her
su tüketilen tepkime hidroliz midir
Hayır hocam mesela fotosentezde de su
tüketilebilir o besin sentezidir
anabolik bir olaydır gibi Peki
homeostazi ayrı bir başlığımız olacak
zaten oraya bırak balım boşaltım
metabolik faaliyetler sonucu oluşan
karbondioksit gibi su gibi amonyak üre
ürik asit gibi azotlu bileşiklerin
hücreden ya da vücuttan
uzaklaştırılmasıdır Burada en alta
sindirim sonucu oluşan atıkların
vücuttan dışarı atılması şeklinde bir
cümle var Bu biraz tehlikeli bir cümle
Çünkü sindirim sistemi ile üriner sistem
aynı değildir üriner sistem genel
bilinen adıyla boşaltım sistemi
Böbrekler ve idrar yoluyla yaptığımız
sindirim sistemi ise işte ağız yutak
yemek borusu mide ince bağırsak kalın
bağırsak rektum anüs şeklinde besin
artıklarını attığımız şeydir Fakat
burada sindirimle ilgili bir ifadeyi
boşaltım başlığının altına koymuş
olmalarının en önemli nedeni şudur Biz
aslında karaciğer aracılığıyla safraya
safra aracılığıyla bağırsak ve dışkıya
attığımız birtakım metabolik atıklar var
Onlardan en önemlisi safranın
içerisindeki Bilirubin gibi maddedir
Bilirubin nedir hocam Bilirubin Bizim
Kanımızı parçaladığı zaman al Yuvarlar
mızın içindeki hemoglobinden ayrılan
maddelerdir yani Dolayısıyla karaciğer
aracılığıyla Safra kesesinde
biriktirilen safranın içerisinde
kolesterol gibi Bilirubin gibi safra
asitleri ya da tuzları gibi maddeler
bağırsak yoluyla dışarı atılabilir
Sindirimdeki bütün olaylar Boşaltıma
dahil edilmez metabolik artıkların
atıldığı durumlar Boşaltıma dahil edilir
bil Rubin dışkıya renk veren maddedir
aynı zamanda bil Rubin bebeklerde
sarılığa neden olan maddedir aynı
zamanda Eğer mesela dahiliyede
arkadaşlar gastroenterolojide
Bilirubin neden yol gösterir bize bir
bakıyoruz ki mesela dışkı renksiz Demek
ki Bilirubin mekanizmasında
metabolizmasında bir problem var yani
renksiz dediğim bambaşka bir enge sahip
gibi çıkarım yapmamızı sağlayacak bir
moleküldür aynı zamanda onu da şimdiden
genel kültür olarak bilin istedim tek
hücreli bir canlıysa Zardan maddeyi atar
kurtulur ama çok hücreli doku organ
sistem organizma düzeyinde bir
canlıysa Siz hücren yarattığınız bir
artık maddeyi Ne yapıyorsunuz dolaşıma
veriyorsunuz dolaşımda yani kana
verdiğinizde O da gidiyor böbreklere
Böbreklerden de bu Dışarı atılıyor bu
şekilde üriner sistemi de İleride
öğreneceğiz
damlama Yaprak Dökümü bir başka canlının
yani Bitkilerde görülen boşaltım
mekanizmasına örnek olur arkadaşlar
büyüme ve gelişme arasındaki farka
dikkat edeceğiz demiştik büyüme tek
hücreli bir
canlıysa artışıdır Şimdi burada en çok
yapılan hatayı söyleyeyim size Mesela 12
sınıfta test çözüyorsunuz diyorsunuz ki
tek hücreli bir canlı bölünerek büyür
Hayır tek hücreli bir canlı
bölündüğünde üremiş olur O yüzden tek
hücreli bir canlı nasıl büyür sorusunun
cevabı hacminin ya da kütlesinin
artmasıyla olur hocam Tamam burayı
karıştırmayın ama çok hücreli senin
benim gibi canlılarda büyüme nasıl olur
Hücre sayısının artışıyla olur her bir
hücremiz hacminin kütlesinin artışıyla
olur ve burada genel bir ifade var
hayvanlarda büyüme sınırlı Ken
bitkilerde yaşamı boyunca devam eder bu
genel bir ifadedir şme nedir hocam
dikkat canlının sahip olduğu yapıların
zamanla görevini yapacak olgunluğa
ulaşmasıdır yani fonksiyonel hale
gelmesidir Bu da gelişme büyüme ile
gelişme Aynı şey değildir burada çok
güzel bir örnek verilmiş yeni doğan bir
bebeğin kilo alması büyümeye Ama zamanla
emeklemeye başlaması yürümeye başlaması
gelişmeye örnek verilebilir basitleştir
Elim daha anlaşılır hale gelsin üremeden
bahsedeceğiz üremede eşeyli ve eşeysiz
üreme olmak üzere iki Temel başlık
olacak ve şunu çok net bir şekilde
bilmenizi istiyorum döllenme varsa
eşeyli üremedir yoksa eşe üremedir Yani
bir şeyde herhangi bir bölünme tipi ya
da ona benzer bir madde aramayın
arkadaşlar döllenme varsa eşe üremedir
ve prokaryot dediğimiz bakterilerde ve
arkelerde arkadaşlar bunlarda mitoz
olmayacak mayoz olmayacak eşeyli üreme D
yok diye olmayacak Tamam şimdiden
bunları böyle bir kenara yazın bakteri
ve arkelerde mitoz mayoz eşeyli üreme
döllenme gibi şeyler yok demek ki
döllenme varsa eşeyli üreme yoksa
eşeysiz üreme üremenin temel mantığında
Ne var peki hocam canlı neslinin devamı
için yeni bireyler meydana getirmek
üremedir ama bazı canlıların üremedi
yini bilelim uyarılara tepki etkiye
tepki verme hocam Burada normal şart lar
altında gözle görülebilen işte bir
hayvanın başka bir hayvanı kovalaması
bitkinin ışığa yönelmesi Tamam ama
moleküler düzeyde de senin görmediğin
bilmediğin bir sürü tepki davranışı var
İlla her tepkiyi göreceksin diye bir şey
yok tamam mesela vücut sıcaklığının
değişmesi fizyolojik bir tepkidir demiş
kitabımız gelelim homeostaziye
homeostazi değişen çevre koşullarına
rağmen canlının iç dengesini kararlı
tutması durumudur yani kararlı bir ortam
yaratması durumudur mesela dışarısı 40
derece de olsa -40 derece de olsa sizin
Vücut sıcaklığını 36 derece civarında
tutulmaya çalışılır ya da kan ph'ını 7.4
civarında tutulmaya çalışılır yine
kanınızın ozmotik basıncı belli bir
değerde tutulmaya çalışılır neden
hayatta kalabilir diye mesela K pH'ı 7.4
6.8 7.9 olursa yaşamla
bağdaşmayan dar bir Aralıkta yaşıyoruz
Aslında o yüzden biz ne diyoruz canlı İç
denge ini korumak için birtakım
tepkimeler gerçekleştirir ve bu
tepkimelerin bütünü Aslında kararlı bir
ortam oluşturmak içindir Bu da
homeostazi adını alır canlıların
sağlıklı bir şekilde yaşaması için
gerekli olan önemli bir düzenleme
mekanizmasıdır demiş kitabımız çok da
güzel bir cümle bu işte terleme yaparsın
artıklarını atarsın senin hayatını
tehlikeye sokabilecek herhangi bir
maddeyi uzaklaştırırsın bu hep
homeostaziye hizmet eder geldim
Varyasyon ve adaptasyona Varyasyon
variation çeşitlilik demekti ama tür içi
çeşitlilik demekti genetiğin ve çevrenin
etkisi ile aynı tür bireyler arasında
görülen farklılıklardır mesela İnsanlar
da birbirine çok benzemez değil mi Göz
rengimiz işte saç rengimiz saç Şeklimiz
deri rengimiz vesaire Bunlar nedir
varyasyonlu göllenme mantığını düşünün
bambaşka iki insanın Üreme hücreleri bir
araya geliyor ve her iki insanın sahip
olduğu DNA özelliklerinin bir kısmı yeni
yavruya aktarılıyor ve o aktarım
sırasında işte Crossing over olayı
olabiliyor homolog kromozomların
rastgele ayrılması oluyor hocam Ne
diyorsun işte bunlar mitoz ve mayozu
size anlatırken söyleyeceğimiz şeyler
Merak etmeyin yani DNA Temelli
farklılıklarımız Türe de yansıyor türün
içerisindeki bireylere de yansıyor Onu
söylemeye çalışıyor Bu cümle genetik
varyasyonlar genellikle kalıtsaldır ve
Sahip olduğunuz özellikleri yavruya
aktarmak için üreme yoluna gidersiniz Bu
da nesilden nesile aktarılır şeklinde
yorumlanabilir
adaptasyon Bir canlının hayatta
kalabilmek için yani o ortama o sürece
uyum sağlaması durumudur ancak
adaptasyon bir sonuç mudur sadece hayır
aslında bir süreci de ifade eder Yani
adapte olma süreci ve adaptasyon sonucu
Aslında ikisi beraber değerlendirilmeli
ne demek istiyorsun hocam adaptasyon
sadece bir sonuç değildir o olayların
tamamı bütün Silsile yani adapte
olabilmek için yaptığın yapacağın her
şeyin sürecidir Aslında adaptasyon
canlının uyum sağlama süreci ve sürecin
sonunda sahip olduğu özelliklerdir
adaptasyon en bilimsel tanım bu mesela
hocam bir canlının bir ortamda kamuflaj
özelliği göstermesi bir adaptasyondur
bakın Bu kalemun ortamın rengine almış
Hemen niye avından avcısından
saklanabilmesi kolaylaştıran bir
adaptasyona ihtiyacı var Halbuki
güvercinin böyle bir özelliğe ihtiyacı
yok Dolayısıyla canlı bulunduğu ortama
yaşadığı ortama adapte olabilmek için
birtakım özellikler geliştirir ama
temelinde yine ne vardır yine
mutasyonlar yine eşeyli üreme yine gen
kombinasyonları vardır Bunu da
unutmayalım sadece hayvan özelinde mi
konuşalım hocam hayır Mesela bitkilerde
de bir sürü adaptasyon görüyoruz kurak
bölge bitkilerinin yapraklarının küçük
Hatta diken şeklini aldığını mesela
kaktüste diken yapraktır ya da nemli
bölge bitkilerinin yapraklarının daha
geniş olduğunu görürsünüz Neden Çünkü
zaten nemli bölge bitkisi kaybedeceği su
umrunda bile değil zaten suya
ulaşabiliyor Dolayısıyla canlı yaşadığı
ortama uyum sağlamak durumundadır Aksi
halde yok
olur burada bir etkinliğimiz var işte
bir hayvan ve bitkiyi 3 gün boyunca
kararlı bir şekilde gözlemleyin ya da
gözlemleyiniz Ancak varlığını bildiğiniz
canlılık özelliklerini işaretleyin
tabloda gösterin gibi Aslında birkaç
tane soru var Ben burada kedi ve çam la
alakalı genel geçer İfadeler kullandım
kim ototrof kim Eter etrofil eşeyli kim
eşeysiz işte kimin büyümesi sınırlı
sınırsız kimde uyarıları tepki var
şeklinde ufak bir yorum yaptım zaten Siz
de pdf'i kontrol edersiniz incelenen
canlıların gözlenemeyen özelliklerinde
Hücresel yapı adaptasyon Varyasyon
organizasyon homeostazi metabolizma İşte
buna daha başka bir sürü Az önce
konuştuğumuz her şeyi ekleyebilirsiniz
işte Enerji dönüşümü ya da boşaltım gibi
Aslında İkisinde de olmalı şeklinde
sonuç çıkarabilirsiniz Şimdi gelelim
virüslere virüsler Latince zehir
anlamına geliyor canlı mı cansız mı
olduğu tartışma konusu şimdi virüslerle
alakalı detaylı bir video çek miştim
zamanında tyt'ye hazırlanan
arkadaşlarınız için ama onun da linkini
aşağı bırakacağım açıklamalar kısmına
Hani Oradan da bir şeyler
anlayabilirsiniz arkadaşlar Çünkü size
burada kitap içerisinde bir ödev
verilmiş o ödevde Kare kod okutularak
virüslerle alakalı detaylı bilgiye
Ulaşılması istenmiş O yüzden Arkadaşlar
onu da izlemenizi tavsiye ediyorum
virüsler Hücresel yapı değildir hücre
zarı sitoplazma çekirdek ya da diğer
organellere sahip değildirler canlı
cansız arasında geçiş formu olarak kabul
eden kaynaklar var ama ne canlı ne
cansız canlı deme sebepleri şu içinde
DNA ya da RNA her ikisi olmaz etrafında
bir protein kılıf ki buna çoğunlukla
kapsit diyorlar Bir de bir canlı Hücre
içine girince çoğalabilir tek başına
yapamıyor Ama bir canlı içerisine
girince o canlının maddelerini
kullanarak sayısını artırabiliyor O
yüzden biz virüslere zorunlu hücre içi
parazit de diyoruz Peki cansız özelliği
ne az önce saydığım şeyler bir kere
hücresel yapıya sahip değil işte Az önce
saydığımız boşaltım homeostaz iler
etkiye tepki verme vesaire Bunlar yok
Neden Çünkü cansız bir ortamda virüs
kristaliz deir Yani herhangi bir
etkinlik faaliyet gösteremez Dolayısıyla
canlı mı cansız mı tartışması Bu yüzden
var her iki tarafa ait de özellikler
içerdiği için geçiş olarak görülüyor
virüsler Şimdi burada ben birkaç kelime
yazmışım hocalarıma Hücresel yapı
metabolizma vurgusu yapın Virüsler canlı
mı cansız mı diye sorulduğu zaman işte
hücre zarı Yok sitoplazması yok
metabolizması yok ama burada bir şey
daha söylemek istiyorum bir farkındalık
yaratabilmek için biz bir şeye canlı
demek için aslında Ne arıyoruz biliyor
musunuz kapalı bir sistem arıyoruz yani
hücre zarıyla çevrilmiş içerisinde
kendine ait bir ortam oluşan bir varlık
arıyoruz bir organizma arıyoruz
Dolayısıyla bu varsa evet Bak burada bir
canlılık var diyoruz ama virüste böyle
bir şey yok hocam hücre zarı yok Kendine
ait metabolik faaliyetlerini
geliştirebileceği ya da dış ortamda
sürekli madde alışverişi yapabileceği
bir sistemi yok Ancak bir hücre
içerisine giriyor ve o hücre içerisinde
o hücrenin materyallerini kullanarak bir
şey yapabiliyor dediğim gibi ne tam
olarak canlı diyebilirsiniz ne tam
olarak cansız diyebilirsiniz arada bir
yere virüsleri koyabilirsiniz virüsler
Tabii salgın hastalıklarda karşımıza
çıkıyor son zamanlarda işte
koronavirüsten kaynaklı artık hepimiz
virüslere karşı bir farkındalık edindik
ama sadece bununla da kalmıyor aynı
zamanda kuduz virüsü diye bir virüs de
vardır ki ülkemiz maalesef birazcık
tehlike Danger Zone dediğimiz bir
durumda tehlikeli durumda dikkat etmekte
fayda var bir sürü Viral enfeksiyon var
hepatitler de mesela viral enfeksiyondur
çiçek hastalığı da viral enfeksiyondur
gibi Aslında virüslerin bizim başımıza
bela olduğu çok hastalık var dikkatli
olmak ve bilinçli olmak
lazım bir oyun yapılmış oyun verilmiş
son olarak bu oyundan bahsedelim hocam
metabolizma homeostazi boşaltım
organizasyon ücel Yapı üreme beslenme
enerji kullanımı uyarılara tepki büyüme
ve gelişime uyum bunlara kartlarda
verilen kelimeleri kullanmadan ulaşmamız
gerekiyor işte hocam arkadaşıma Ne
sorarsam metabolizmayı
söyleyebilir kimyasal tepkimelerin
bütünüdür
diyebiliriz homeostazi için aslında
kararlı ortamı sağlama şeklinde bir
cümle kurabiliriz boşaltım için
metabolizma sonucu oluşan zararlı ya da
fazla maddeleri uzaklaştırma nedir
şeklinde soru sorabiliriz Kendine benzer
canlı oluşturma canlının canlılık
özelliği gösteren en küçük yapı birimi
nedir şeklinde soru sorabiliriz
organizasyon için basitten karmaşa
mantığı var Evet organizasyon mantığı
Hücre doku organ sistem organizma
şeklinde
gidebiliyorsan için canlıların hayatta
kalmak için ihtiyaç duyduğu güç kaynağı
ifadesi kullanılabilir çevresel ya da
içsel değişikliklere yanıt verme nedir
yine kelimeleri kullanmadan böyle bir
soru sorabilir
kütle hacim artışı neye karşılık gelir
işlevi yapabilecek hale gelmek neye
karşılık gelir şeklinde bir soru
sorabilirsiniz değişen çevre şartlarına
ayak uydurma nedir tarzında bir soru
sorduğunuzda arkadaşınızdan uyum
adaptasyon cevabını alabilirsiniz Evet
bitirdik bu şekilde Aslında biyoloji ile
alakalı 4 yıl boyunca Neler göreceğinizi
de özetlemiş olduk Lütfen bu Dersin
sonunda Eyvah bir bioloji çok zor ya da
biyoloji yapılamaz biyolojide her şeyi
ezberlemek zorundayım tarzında bir cümle
kurmayın burada barış hocanız diğer
hocalarla beraber çalışarak size Aslında
biyolojide 4 yıl boyunca Neyi
göreceksiniz ve nasıl hazırlık yapmanız
gerekiyor Onu anlatmaya çalıştı Umarım
anlaşılmıştır hepinize kolay gelsin